[Music]
solidarity has always been at the heart
of the European community seventy years
ago on May the 9th 1950 Robert Schumann
made a revolutionary declaration with
Europe ravaged by the Second World War
Schumann planted the seed from which the
European community of peace grew and
blossomed former enemies reached out
their hands in reconciliation and became
friends we opened borders and tore down
the walls between us we built the
world's biggest internal market with the
continent to reunified the European
family finally
again against all odds we built a unique
society in Europe where we can live
together in peace and solidarity today
70 years after the Schumann declaration
Europeans are confronted with the
deepest crisis since the second world
war too many have lost loved ones are
fighting for their own lives or are
afraid of losing their jobs their
livelihoods their future still in the
midst of today's crisis the European
spirit of solidarity was rekindled
leaving borders open for critical
transports of food and medical goods
helping EU citizens travel safely home
supporting neighboring countries with
medical staff investing massive
resources to find a vaccine in the midst
of this crisis new heroes had emerged
[Music]
they are our inspiration now we are
called upon to walk in the footsteps of
Schumann to write the next chapter in
our history it is time to rebuild Europe
with a new recovery plan and a heart it
is time for a Europe where workers have
a good job to return to after the crisis
where companies receive a helping hand
especially in hard-hit sectors Europe
where we harvest the energy of Sun wind
and water to fuel our cars homes and
factories a Europe where we join forces
and invest in research to give citizens
the health care they need it is time to
help each other become stronger together
it's time to be brave to stand up and
build a better future it is time to make
history again
[Music]